I Dunno.
It's,
it's,
I,
I honestly,
I would say to an extent,
there's probably some kind of tribal bias.
Well,
I think when you're going back to high school yearbooks,
looking for outrage from 55 year old people,
if you've lost the plot,
you've lost.
Isn't that?
Isn't that crazy?
It's fucking insane.
What's,
what's crazier is when Kathy Griffin tweets out that the three point or hand
sign at a Covington basketball game was a Nazi hand gesture.
Like the three point or you know,
the 3.9 is this thing.
Yup.
Yeah.
Oh,
see,
I'm not going to do it because the photos a little flying people send me death
threats and a series of them on my Instagram.
When I found out about proof,
I put bill Cosby doing it.
I had someone found one of me from news radio.
Isn't it?
Aren't they using it though for that symbol?
I know that it's a,
it's a universal symbol.
That means a lot of things.
I'm using it as that symbol there.
They're not using it to mean white power and other not.
All right.
What are the ones not.
Okay.
What were those cops using it for?
That's the,
that's the,
uh,
the,
what is it called?
It's called the okay game.
That don't look game where you put the symbol under your waist and if someone
looks at you get to punch him.
What is,
there's a game kids play?
No,
no,
no.
The Swat cops that had it on their,
on their legs.
No,
there were all doing it.
There was like four of them doing it in a photograph and holding it up or they
holding it on their legs.
Ooh,
I dunno know.
No,
but I don't know.
Let's,
let's,
let's break this down.
I can explain this to you.
Okay.
Please do.
Donald Trump,
when he talks,
he makes the okay hand sign.
He's pointing,
he's making,
I mean,
okay,
if he does it this way,
is that okay?
Oh No,
I already does this.
No,
I don't care what Trump does,
what he does,
flex people off.
It's probably a bad thing,
but,
so what happens is he starts doing the,
okay,
10.
Okay sign.
So bunch of Trump supporters start doing it too,
to be like,
Hey,
I'm like Trump.
Right,
right.
A four Chan campaign gets started saying,
convince everyone.
That's actually means white power.
Right.
It was fake.
The Anti Defamation League said it was fake.
Yes.
A bunch of journalists said it was real.
That's what I put on my Instagram.
Yeah.
Put all this on my Instagram,
including the article where it showed the original thing came from fortune,
fortune.
It's fucking hilarious.
Powerful.
It's Ho.
It's hilarious how much shit they start.
They started the flat earth movement.
Okay.
There's the guy.
Oh,
is that?
I don't,
I never heard that.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They started to Futz with it.
Let's look at this photo and see if I can give you a little,
it popped up to conspiracy.
How do we get it back?
It's that what's going on?
The connection to the TV's just died out.
I have no idea.
It's a Hollywood conspiracy.
The button that I have is making it go there and it's not going there,
so I don't know.
Jesus Chamie.
There's Gremlins in this fucking room.
I would figure it out.
It's hard to,
allegedly,
I would say this.
We need to see that though.
90 yeah,
show.
Show me a new laptop.
I would,
I would be willing to,
okay.
There's the image.
Take a good look at it,
Tim.
So,
okay.
These guys,
they see what's on their leg.
Yes.
That's specifically a game where when you look at it,
they get to punch you.
What?
That they're not holding the hand sign up.
They're not flashing it like you see like conservatives do.
Right.
I'm not denying that as a game,
but to say that that's what those guys are doing is a bit of a stretch,
I believe.
Well,
what do you think they're doing?
What does it as to say that if,
if fortune did that to,
to make to,
to mix it up.
At some point people would think that that is true though.
That's like no way that's happening.
I'll say,
this is it.
Is it?
Well,
this would be bleeding free.
Bleeding came from fortunate.
If you don't know what right,
let's explain that to people.
It's all you.
Okay.
Free bleeding was fortunate.
I thought it would be hilarious.
By the way,
Shiela bu was at the fucking comedy store last night.
I wonder why,
because we're always ragging on him.
Um,
free bleeding came from four Chan where they said that they were,
they were promoting this idea that for women's rights that they would,
you know,
get away with their clothes,
get away from this whole idea of you have to control your menstrual cycle.
You know,
it's empowering to just bleed all over your crunch.
And so women actually started doing it because it actually,
if you can fucking,
if you can get those ideas out there,
a certain number of knuckleheads are going to take it and run with it and think
it's real.
Of course.
So you don't think that's possible with the white power though?
I think it's extremely unlikely.
I think it's,
it's possible.
So here's the thing,
nothing's absolute right.
Are there some,
some white supremacists who are doing it for sure,
but you don't,
you think you're looking at bad asses with fucking guns.
They're playing this little silly game.
Yeah.
Really.
I think there are a bunch of bros.
Who are you ever,
do you ever hang out with?
Like some Frat dudes at a college,
they punch each other.
That's there's a game.
So how does it go again?
You,
you make the okay hand sign.
Okay.
And you hold it.
These are a table or on on your leg.
These are adults.
These are guys that are not in college.
They're definitely not a below 25 years old.
But what does that mean?
I know,
I know 40 year old guys who play Pokemon,
I know belongs to them and go,
this is a game that fix this fucking thing.
Well I don't.
That's okay.
But what the general,
what is their job?
What would they their swat team guys?
Is that what they did?
They were arresting a drug dealer.
And what do you,
what do you think they're doing?
They're trying to make sure everybody knows that they're there.
They're flashing and overt white power,
hand gesture because everyone knows that's what it means.
That's,
I didn't think everyone knew well now that's just not,
it's just not the case.
The thing,
the point is holding the,
okay,
sign up next to you is what's key.
You know,
people say it's the w in the peat,
putting it on your leg has always been the punch him game or whatever.
Like I don't know,
I know that punch him,
punch him,
gave 100%,
you put it at the okay symbol on your leg or under a table and you say,
hey look.
And if they look at it and see it,
they go ah,
and then you punch him in the arm.
But I know it so well that I,
that's why I don't think that's what they're doing like me and my friends.
So one of the lay it.
So then the question is it's a major look made you look major.
Look right.
So,
but what are they doing right?
Look,
look,
listen man.
If you want to,
if you want to make assumptions about what you think their intentions were,
that's all you.
I don't have any facts to support that.
And the only thing I know of is there as a game where you put the okay sign in
your leg and then you punch somebody.
And here's some guys putting the okay sign in their leg.
What evidence do we have?
It's anything other than that.
Nothing.
So that,
that's,
I'm not going to go any further than that.
I'm going to say,
was it poor judgment?
Oh hell yeah.
Maybe.
But listen,
do you know about what happened in Philly with these marines who got beat up by
Antifa?
No,
I do not.
So there's some,
so there was a,
a rally put on by some,
uh,
constitutional libertarians.
I don't know exactly what it was all about.
Antifa shows up in protests.
Some marines apparently are just walking by because there was a marine event.
Antifa sees them and yells,
are you proud?
They said,
he says,
I'm a marine and said,
are you a proud boy?
And he said,
you know,
I don't know.
They beat him up.
These,
uh,
they arrested several people charged with multiple felonies.
Marines got beat up.
They didn't know it.
Proud boy was.
So to assume that these guys know anything about what's going on in in cultural
politics.
It's,
it's,
you know when you're in the know and you're on Twitter,
when you're reading the news all day,
you look at the insight,
they knew what they were doing,
what these are small like what city of these guys from even do they watch the
news all day?
Do they go on four Chan,
do they go on vox.com and read and know what this is about?
Okay.
I appreciate your looking at this with a broad perspective,
but it is entirely possible that the did,
sure.
It's also entirely possible that within their friend group it means you're
buying lunch.
It could mean a million things.
It could mean,
but in the cultural context of 2018 when this happened.
Yup.
That,
oh the okay symbol doesn't even mean white power.
It is,
is,
it is.
It is a tribal sign among anti anti intersectional and Trump supporters.
But don't you remember when w was there?
There was a woman that got in trouble for,
she was in court and she had it on her arm.
She was just standing there like some insane,
so insane because she was basically,
she had her finger and her thumb like that.
Yeah.
They said and they,
and they went wild with it.
Yeah.
She's making somebody powers.
You have to understand when I see that and I see that you kicked me out,
but there's a difference between someone just moving their hands around and
doing this and you know,
making a weird thing she did.
She did fall on do it the next day though.
Probably on purpose.
Maybe that's what she does when she puts it on there.
You have to assume she's watching the news then I would,
she's sitting at the cabin out hearing.
But it's entirely possible though.
I'll be an unlikely that she was just telling somebody.
Okay.
Like,
or she was,
she's used to doing that with her arm.
There's new,
think about it.
There's,
you're allowed to make assumptions,
right.
And operate off assumptions.
But eventually you start getting off so crazy and you know how many assumptions
are going to believe until you're believe in the moon.
Landing was fake.
Let me ask you this though.
Don't you think that some people do that and they do it because they're making
the symbol for white power?
Some as in what,
10 1520 I don't know.
I think,
I don't know about,
and like I said,
listen,
nothing's absolute.
I'd be,
I'm pretty sure there are probably some white supremacists who do that.
But here's the thing,
most of these people who are on four Chan,
who would even use the Emoji who would do it in public,
they're not doing it to signal white power.
They're doing it a signal opposition to the tribal left when they take photos
and you see someone like Cassandra Fairbanks who is a Trump supporting,
you know,
writer.
She has,
she,
she is,
she's notable because she stood at the podium,
made the okay hand sign and then this writer from splinter news,
which uh,
used to be called fusion worked there,
full disclosure,
claimed it was a white power hand gesture and she,
she got Kasandra sued over it.
She ultimately lost,
cause it's like,
you know,
free slander is hard to sue for.
But she did it because it was a Trump sign.
Not because it's white power.
So the people who were even white supremacists aren't signifying white power.
They're signaling to other Trump supporters too.
Right?
It doesn't mean white power.
Right.
So just because someone on the left says it means,
why power,
that does not mean it means why power within their group.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
Just like we all just decide that this means something else.
Like my friend means a piece among peers,
among nations,
my peace among worlds.
My friend Steve Rinella.
Uh,
we talked about this in the podcast that he got beat up wants by his friend
where uh,
he grew up in Michigan and in Michigan as almost like for fun.
Like,
like if I said,
hey fucker,
like if I called you,
like as friends.
Yeah.
You would laugh and be like,
what's up dude?
You know,
it'd be cool.
So he would give the bird and they would call it the Michigan.
Hello?
Yup.
And so the Michigan wave or something like that.
So as he's driving by saw as for anyone like that,
like if I saw you do that,
I'd be like,
Eh,
what's up Tim?
There was a,
but you don't have to,
but his friend didn't know this,
so his friend,
he grabbed him through to the ground.
He goes,
you want to fight motherfuckers like,
what are you talking about?
Like what's going on?
He's like,
you gave me the bird.
oh Jesus,
Bro,
I'm from Michigan.
Yeah,
like that's we're having fun.
Like that's just,
I'm your friend and he was over the guy's house helping them build a greenhouse
or something.
Like he was doing some work with the guy.
I think I still threw him to the ground because he thought that this was,
oh,
you got it fixed.
No,
there's naturally,
there's going to be a ton of people,
you know saying,
Oh,
tombs boot licker and all that stuff.
It's like premises men.
Like I'm not,
I,
I do not.
I'm not a big fan of conspiracy theories.
I'm not a big fan of making assumptions about the intentions of other people.
If you can prove it,
I'm willing to hear it.
But people in this country are innocent till proven guilty.
What do we have?
We have a photo of some cops doing something dumb.
Do I think it was ill advised it was wrong.
I should have done it.
Well of course.
Absolutely should have done it.
Do I think it means they're white supremacists?
No,
the tops.
Look,
I've,
I,
I am no fan of police.
you know,
I grew up as like a left far left anarchist skateboarder.
The cop screw with me all the time.
I've had cops kicked my door,
guns drawn.
I was in Chicago and cops pulled me over.
Me and my buddies,
this is all on video at gunpoint screaming at us.
It was the craziest experience I've ever had.
I am no fan,
but if you don't have evidence,
I'm not just going to say this is a thing about how,
how these biases function.
You get people who will see all these videos,
live these experiences and they immediately assume the worst about these guys.
I don't know anything about these guys.
I know they did something dumb,
but I don't know why.
So I can't really go beyond that other than I believe their official statement
was there playing the game.
But I could be wrong,
but to,
to make assumptions about their character or what they believe simply because
they made an okay sign on their leg.
It's like you can't convict somebody in a court.
You know what I mean?
And I'm,
I'm a big fan of the presumption of innocence and Blackstone's formulation and
how we side on the,
uh,
we,
we err on the side of protecting the innocent.
But I think you got a good point in also in the fact that this is a extremely
recent hand gesture that's being associated with white supremacy and clearly
came from pranksters.
And you have to assume these guys are on four Chan or,
or read these,
these websites.
Like,
come on man,
these dudes,
they probably go to work all day.
They talk about football,
they go home,
they sit in their lounge chair and have a beer and a slice of pizza or whatever
it is they do.
I don't think these guys,
people,
man,
you know,
people don't know how to separate their own personal bubble from reality.
They assume if I know it,
you must know it.
Right?
It's actually something,
uh,
Shane Smith told me,
he said he doesn't understand.
Why is it that if he can do it,
you can't.
Right.
And that's,
it's like an interesting point that people don't seem to realize you mean by
that?
Like he's,
he's had to me,
I can speak French.
Why can't you like people live in this mindset where they assume,
if I know it,
everyone knows it.
Right.
Okay.
So,
so they're going to be like,
no,
every,
I saw an article about that.
Everyone must know what it is.
It's like,
no,
no.
Dude.
There are some people who don't watch TV.
There are some people play video games all day.
There's some people who don't do any of that for all,
you know,
these guys,
they,
every day after work,
they go to a children's shelter and,
and provide soup and they don't watch the news at all.
Like I'm not,
I don't believe that they actually do.
I'm just saying,
you have no idea what's going on in their lives.
You're making assumptions about what they know,
who they are.
And I think,
you know,
I,
I'm a firm believer that we have problems with racism in this country.
I believe,
uh,
institutional and systemic racism,
real,
real problems need to be solved.
All that stuff.
That still doesn't mean you get to just label someone and make assumptions about
what they believe,
who they are because of one thing.
You know,
if,
if you've made a,
if you made a joke,
what if,
what if they did it because they were ironically doing it right?
If you made a joke 10 years ago,
am I going assume you actually believe that?
Maybe said something silly.
You know,
we had this newscaster in New York who,
who accidentally said Martin Luther,
you know,
uh,
and I,
and at that point again,
you know,
I was like another one.
Yep.
Sullen.
And you also,
uh,
and another thing happened that no one cared about was a guy on CNN said a
racial slur for Jewish people in the same way.
No one cared about that one,
you know?
So there was a CNN anchor.
What did he say?
I don't want to say it.
Okay,
but he was,
he was his k word,
right?
I think you can still say it as long as I'm going to call me.
It was the same thing.
He quickly fit,
corrected himself.
And that didn't come up as an issue.
But the point is this dude,
you know why?
Why is he being fired?
Right,
right.
Even people came to his defense,
are you going to assume nasty things about them?
Like are we really getting to the point where we're going to look at a photo?
We don't know the context.
We don't know who these people are.
What are their names?
And we're going to be like burnt at the stake.